I'm Kylie Jenner and I am the founder of
Kylie cosmetics it's been 24 hours of he
said she said between Kylie Jenner and
Alex Rodriguez about what they actually
talked about at the Met Gala but now
they are setting the record straight
that's three wines and the new issue of
Sports Illustrated a rod says he shared
a table with Kendall and Kylie inside
the bash it's very exciting and right
down the street from Yankee Stadium
we're so lucky to be a part of this
night quote Kylie was talking about
Instagram and her lipstick and how rich
she is
but according to Kylie that's not really
true she defended herself on Twitter
clapping back wins um no I didn't we
only spoke about Game of Thrones and
yeah that tweet has already been
retweeted over 10,000 times and liked
over a hundred and fifty thousand times
I put so much love into everything that
I make and I make sure everything is
perfect but here's where it gets funny a
rod also tweeted agreeing with Kylie
quote oMG that's right Kylie Jenner it
was me talking about you and your makeup
line and how much my girls love you
hashtag G ot hashtag respect hashtag all
love I'm confused why would he say that
in the first place did he make it up did
he forget it's weird one thing we do
know to be true
Kylie is really rich last year Forbes
named her the youngest self-made
billionaire oh because of those
lipsticks and her Kylie cosmetics line
starting a company on my own and it
being so big from the beginning there's
not a lot of room for mistakes and
Kylie's family has had a lot to say
about her success sister Kourtney wasn't
so positive about things on their show
earlier this month but Kim and Mama Kris
have always had Kylie's back she works
really hard she made her own money for
over a decade she put it in the bay she
saved every nickel and then
she decided she really you know decided
on what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well
not like that was handed to her she
figured that all out I mean we all have
and there you have it what do you guys
make of this whole a rod and Kylie
situation let me know and for all the
latest on the Kardashians be sure to
keep it locked to all things
ét until next time I'm Katie crafts and
bye for now